Còn khói không lộ bốc cao hàng chục mệt sau vụ nổ đổi nhà khó tụng nổ ở miệng mà khi lýt nhất 1 mối mối sống ở thì mà.
Vụ nổ sây ra chưa bà mốt thằng năm ở lặng công tút, bằng sàn, tại một nhà khó chưa lựng lượng lượng nổ phụ vụ hãn đậu khai thác mỏ.
Cô vực sây ra sự cố thuộc quyền kiểm soát của lực lượng quân giải pham dân tập tà ăn, TNLA,
hình ảnh từ hiện chương cho thấy một quả cầu lượng bùng lên giữ rồi, nhiều vụ nổ thứ cấp tiếp tục phần ra sau đó,
sự áp từ vụ nổ phá hủy khu vực xung quanh làm hư hại hàng loạt mua nhà gần hiện chương.
CNLA lựa lượng cứu hộ cho biết ít nhất bụ miệng sống người thêm mạc, bởi miếng tức người bị thương và hơn 1 trong vô nhà biển hưởng.
Lựa lượng quân đội TNLA sẽ nhận số tục nổ là chất Zélineite, ra bộ phật kinh tế của nhóm quanh lý,
cho biết đây là tay nạn ngoài im muốn và đáng đều tra mình nhận.
Zélineite là loại thuốc nổ thường được sự dụng trong khai khoảng và phá đá, nhưng có thể chở nên mất ổn định nếu bảo quanh công đúng cách,
hoặc lúc chưa trong thời gian dài.